Japanese pop star Namie Amuro will retire next year.
The singer announced on her 40th birthday, September 20th,...
...that she will quit the showbiz on September 16th, 2018.
The surprise announcement follows Saturday's concert in her home prefecture of Okinawa...
...to celebrate the 25th anniversary of her music career.
On her official website, the pop star said,...
..."I plan to make the last year of my music career meaningful...
...by focusing my full attention on creating a final album and performing at concerts."
Amuro rose to fame as a teen idol after making her professional debut in 1992...
...and becoming a fashion icon in the 90s with a strong fan base in Asia.
She has had a long and storied career, having sold more albums in Japan...
...than Lady Gaga, Katy Perry and Kesha have in the US combined,...
...according to Entertainment Weekly.
For United News International in Tokyo, I'm Rumi Fukushima.